okay well for those of you who are
watching this live stream you are
dropping in on another episode of our
real life software architecture and this
is a meeting of our language
completeness and consistency group going
over a variety of detailed things for
the upcoming version of orphan language
so let us start off with read byte array
without further ado umm Oh something is
wrong with my doggy tools again does
anybody know what's causing this well
when I press get function page it
doesn't work this is the exact same bug
that I've reported multiple times do you
know what the cause is no I don't know
what the cause is but we have reported
it multiple times yes
and has it been looked at or not I know
Brian says he will look at it and that
doesn't really help us does it
it's the problem sorry Jane probably not
when you can help with its it's the UM
that doggie tools is not opening let's
try it again okay well this time it
worked so let's just be happy um okay so
I'm gonna I'm gonna open this
documentation 11 - um is that going to
be okay or should I try to open it 11 3
well for some of the graphic design
things you'll need it in 11 3 prototype
build or regular yes
oops okay let's start with read byte
array anyway okay so is this this is all
new documentation what is what is read
bytes did we end up with us or are we
calling these things read byte array
what's the difference I guess I I
haven't updated the there there is no
right fights I don't think I don't think
that yeah I think it should be right
byte array if it's read by to rate
better be right by - right right except
right directly supports byte arrays so
we done I don't think we really need a
right vitam
what do you mean right supports might
arise so if you if you have a byte array
and well this is right into a channel
aha so everything's rating to a channel
right bytes does not write to a byte
array it writes every file yeah I
understand that
so what are you saying so you're saying
if that second argument is a byte array
it will simply what does right in anyway
I mean followed by a new line to a
specified output channel that doesn't
sound very felicitous yeah I guess I
look at binary right which would be the
relevant
so again I guess it's still futurist for
some reason but it actually works future
eyes it which version did it on future
isin I think it either 11 1 or 11 -
those are no examples dad I don't know
about okay well how about another one
who's who's okay so can you chase that
down please
um I'm get that defeats rise make sure
it has examples okay okay so now why is
this so binary read is different from
read by to write yes because
in the binary for a couple of reasons
one is that in binary read we don't
really have a way to specify how many
bytes we want to read okay
this reads from a byte array object
instead of from a stream and it's been
future eyes here that is something that
tally stuck in there years ago and
there's no implementation that I'm aware
of so wait a minute what this is doing
read byte array is reading from a source
to a byte array object okay so it's the
analog of read string or I think it's
more analogous to read list only or
binary read list only rather than
returning a
then returning a list it returns a
battery so in some sense it really
should be called binary read byte array
yes and what would a nan
so okay because reads string for example
is just reading read string just reads a
string well it reads so this by the way
should be documented in parallel to read
string I mean it should say reads the
complete contents of a file and returns
it as a byte array okay and this whole
thing about you know streams and
processes and things like that well I
think I think read string is the odd man
out and it should be read strings should
be made to look like read byte array I
don't fix her because I think this is
very useful to see those different cases
there that's the reason I think it's
important no no no that's it that is
just plain wrong I mean like with the
binary with like right we say channel we
don't say I'm or swim or process yeah
I'm aware
oh well well read string should be made
to conform tonight I don't think so I
think that this is what people for
people who are actually going to read
string they are thinking you know read
string is a simple function and they are
going to be confused if it says channel
and they're not going to understand what
it is well so it can say source yeah but
I understand either way it doesn't
matter it's whatever I don't think it's
that important I think this is better
which is why I did it that way but I
think it doesn't really matter what you
know read byte array is already a more
sophisticated function so it's less
important okay so let's take a look at
this so this is saying so this second
argument n is analogous to binary read
list right the fact that has an N there
is an analogous to what happens in
binary read lists and well actually okay
n objects all the fault of the specified
types right yeah
now okay so the problem is oh boy
so again what I'm sorry what was it now
I'm already confused what was the analog
of right bytes binary what was it the
analog of that but we've decided which
is what we've decided there there is I
mean there is no analog of right bytes
mmm right bytes is basically binary
right okay so it's binary right you know
the fact that we're getting so confused
about this might make it make sense to
call binary you know okay the only
question is is there any conceivable way
that we could fit read byte array into
binary read not really I mean what
binary does binary read reads reads from
a sequence of objects from a stream it
reads objects so if one of those
possible types was byte array as opposed
to bite why wouldn't that work because
there would be no way to specify the
length or the possible terminators
okay well that does seem to be no third
argument of binary read which we could
use I mean we could even have a case of
binary read in which its binary read of
look we could have binary read of your
stream or source we appear to be
confused in this case about which one it
is
um and then the type would be byte array
and then the
and I mean we could also do yeah the
type would be byte array or or we could
in a possible abuse I don't know do
something like this so that we could fit
that in to the types here so we could
say read that you know read a single
integer then read a length and byte
array
I guess the question is I guess that's a
question for Garrett I mean dude do we
lose all our performance benefit if we
got it here yes if if we if we try to
force this into binary read I think it's
possible
there might be like a tiny bit of
overhead but I think it's negligible I
mean I the only question is whether code
that we'll look we'll start looking
really stupid I mean so this is gonna
have a whole bunch of places where we're
gonna say binary read of a source that
might be a socket for example as a byte
array it doesn't seem totally stupid to
me but I think it doesn't completely
match the types because the types are
types you're looking for when you're
reading all right I mean it's it's
conceptually not really quite the right
thing well it is a type that you're
looking for when you're reading it's a
there's no type of byte array yeah
you're right you're right you're right
you're right and right and also those
types will convert into into orphan
language types which this is not doing
correct yeah you're right okay Garrett
you should speak up because yes you made
a correct point um okay so the only
question is if we're calling a read byte
array I mean I have no problem with
calling it binary read the byte array we
thought that sounds a little funny it
seems kind of stupid look at that thing
so it's an allow like us to read string
what other weed functions are there in
the family there's red line which is red
string with the terminator of new line
right of /r or slash end all right let's
call it read byte array okay let's
figure out what what do we need to
figure out here so n bytes yeah the the
only thing that's a little bit
unfortunate in the way we're currently
writing this is its I mean I think there
are examples which show this but it's
not a hundred percent clear in that that
table of terminators that you know one
of those terminators can maybe I should
just list n number of bytes as a
possible terminator let's do it
okay The Terminator I mean just call it
termination specification can be any of
the following okay I'll put it in here
just for
if I can get this to answer
beginning into that table which of
course I can't are we ever gonna fix
that particular issue or look at that
that inserted okay anyway
n
number of bytes to read read I don't
think this is quite right I mean this
needs to be done better I'm sorry I
didn't do this right all right I'll go
and clean this up I mean there are still
a few bugs in the implementation left so
the examples aren't finalized so I'm
going to need to go back and finish up
the example so I can review this and
okay
is that exactly in bytes or set up to n
bytes that's up to n bytes okay
are you sure you don't want to have a
thing where it's actually unlike some
use up to if you want up to well I think
it could be exactly in the nude parrot
with end of buffer if you wanted up to
because you can have a list of
terminators so end of buffer might be
right so that's so but what about if you
happen I see so what you do if you have
ten you reach ten blocks of ten bites
the
they end up in a single byte array
and Tenten is equivalent to 30 is that
true well it's not looking for a number
of types let's just kind of stop reading
at this point no I think those are Ord
yeah exactly so one one so right those
are there well there are two cases with
possible sub cases right because there's
end of buffer and there's end of a file
or a story sorry I wrote the wrong thing
here what I meant was binary right yes
go ahead
what were you saying so so about the
Otto up to or not up to there are two
cases with possible sub cases so there's
the end of file and there's end of
buffer now with end of file I mean right
you're never going to get there so it'll
just hang forever if you insist on there
being exactly n bytes with end of buffer
and I don't know we have this time
constraint thing oh I see so so within
the buffer we could make it be exactly n
unless you encounter and the file which
may not be such a bad thing but then it
might hang if right well it'll block
until it encounters either n bytes or in
the file I guess that's probably the
right thing but I don't forget to make
time constraint take units
particularly relevant for this
particular function because I can
imagine on some embedded device saying
read byte arrived for two hours and it
just keeps on trying to see what comes
in over two hour period right so I think
well we'll need to sort of make that
consistent across all of the read
functions that take a time constraint I
think it's certainly consistent across
the URL reading functions right now
that's supposed to be okay but please
continue I don't completely understand
this the their list of terminators okay
so if I say so go to an example there's
an example like he means a third one
under scope
[Music]
okay so so go to the third one in this
section I think is the relevant one
third one in this section so here yep
yes exactly
you
I see until either seventy bytes have
been reached or the end of a line is
reached yep okay so if I were to say 70
comma 10 I would just get 10 characters
correct okay all right so I mean in
general I could imagine all kinds of
complicated termination things now for
example in the case of socket
communications and Garrett I you you
will probably know about this what kinds
of things will happen there how do you
know the data is finished in a socket
communication for example a web a web
server contacts you a web a web client
contacts a web server I shall know this
but is it self delimiting how the packet
ends and things right
so there's if you use a specific
protocol you might be able to see the
end of a packet you could read all the
data available which would be to the end
of the buffer and usually if you send
one packet at a time it's not going to
cut it off in the middle
if you've read kind of buffer or if
you're looking for a specific sequence
depending on how you write you could
look for a byte array I mean there's a
couple of ways to do it
does this look for a specific sequence
can I put a character and here a list of
I put a byte array but can I put a guy I
should be able to put a string here as
well
you think a toy the only concern is
sorry I would I muted myself a string is
not and is not is a very ambiguous way
to specify a byte sequence
unless it's pure ASCII well even then
not a hundred percent but there at least
has a chance of yes I mean we could put
a character encoding in this function to
tell you the mapping because I can just
imagine that it would be useful that
there are situations in which there are
protocols where the thing ends like a
mail message or something ends with a
period you know its own line type thing
maybe that doesn't true anymore used to
be true is it still true it might still
be true in smtp not sure okay
another case they um let's look at and a
buffer what is under buffer do we do we
have a thing that was new and ten yes it
was introduced by tally for process link
okay okay fine okay so it's a it's a
thing and when we're reading from
process it will be a reasonable thing to
have here right right okay
what what other issues all that and this
sum I mean I I'm pretty happy with what
there is here I you know there are a few
bugs which will need to be sorted out
but those are really just plain
implementation bugs and not all right
should we be finalizing documentation
here is this the is that objective it
this is yeah I I think I think this is
considering this experimental are we
just making this real I think this one
we can make real okay kaboom
and the ember bug above if you want to
fix that
not really I'm gonna let somebody else
fixed that because all right I'll fix it
when I make a pass um okay
right we need to change that terminators
with termination specification right
reads until the termination
specification of termination criterion
termination specification
satisfied
oh that's that's good I like that yeah
maybe it should say termination
condition is satisfied they'll be better
yes okay gives the reads from source and
gives the result reads maybe what you
have was better
okay um what about a URL
I yeah I I guess I haven't tested that
if I just work I think okay anyway
that's just a comment let's move on here
this needs a bit of rewording and this
during he ties pass he should change
termination specification to a condition
there as well
something like that I'm not sure quite
how to do it button okay um okay this
looks good to me
it isn't it's partially knitted not
fully knitted right it hasn't been back
knitted okay should we move on to the
next item yep
for agonize you will need to use a
prototype build to see this okay fine
to see the graphic design yep okay let's
go there I'm still getting some pushback
on this name I can eyes doesn't I can
eyes doesn't it literally mean make
something a saint
somebody presumably a saint but am i
completely mistaken
well our spell check sure doesn't think
that it's a word that what on earth is
going on here Mathematica has detected
an internal error
the average email why it says
Mathematica there I have no idea and why
it says well okay should I not worry
about that don't worry about that
there's an existing bug report about
that okay
[Music]
Oh canonized as the word
what could I think it was I can either
that's you present and the ease in the
Eastern Church right the icon as his
depiction of a saint
oh okay so then so wouldn't be totally
stupid to think this would right yeah
okay um
right so I have a whole slew of examples
if you wanna know I just want to look at
one thing here
great okay well whatever okay examples
where are they in the rest page okay so
that is not in the prototype build or
it's not no it's not I'm gonna I'm good
at the problem is that I can't open that
in the prototype build so I'm gonna do a
hack here and copy it like this okay
okay do we have folks from design here
oh I can check if we can join no this is
not the final design right so there was
this is not this is I'm not seeing the
blue shade on the background of its that
you've just gone through this okay yeah
this is the final design it looks nice
actually looks yeah there was one
question about the she had the plasma
I'm sorry yeah but shouldn't we be
saying white space count sort of English
rather than white count
isn't that a convention for summary
bulbs yes although given that this is
literally you know white count it's not
totally crazy it's all crazy but I think
we might as well split it yeah what was
the issue about the plus well I mean I I
got multiple messages from different
sources so whether web a whether it
should be identical to summary boxes
plus minus and B well there was some
discussion of possibly changing it for
everybody and so the question is are we
sticking with this you know
so I guess question the most important
question is should I can eyes basically
have the same plus minus is summary
boxes yes okay I opinion I don't think I
mean whether we choose to change all of
them is a different issue I mean it's a
little weird looking but it's not that
weird okay which was which was my
opinion as well I just
given that I got different notes from
different meetings I just wanted to make
sure we're all on board right by the way
I assume that that shade of blue is the
same as the two big shade of blue no
come on guys well you probably can't see
it through the zoom session those Blues
have to match up in my opinion which
blues the blue background for the show
you know for the two big expression
formatting too big an expression and the
blue here the background blue there I
mean they're just different shades of
blue just seems wrong I can follow up
with Jeremy on that yeah Jeremy like
well I guess I thought of that
correspondence yeah I don't remember
anyone mentioning this and I have to say
that I would recommend having good
brother who's shuffling papers or
whatever whatever they're doing if you
could move yourself please um
you
let's see um I was gonna say I I think
my graphic design preference would beat
it that the lightness of that blue is a
little bit too light and that should go
to a darker hue and dark I mean more
more saturated blue for what it's worth
but since we don't have anybody from
graphic design here that's probably not
a useful comment to be making oh yes
okay we'll wait for him okay so okay sup
Billy hi hi there
okay um so first comment was that I
think the blue of this icon eyes box
needs to agree with the blue of the two
big expression box here okay I mean this
is a more gray blue here I don't know if
you can see it through the zoom session
I'm familiar with it I was looking at it
for something else that he was the
progress panel stuff because I was
thinking about how these really are
that's interesting as well right that's
that look we got a standardize on some
blue for these things we can't have six
different we're running around yeah and
I also noticed that this has a gray
border so just figure out what you what
you think should happen there
my preference here is that these arrows
should be a darker blue okay I think it
will be better I just make it make it
work I don't know what exactly the
fingers so okay so here this bold do we
really need to go bold for that name see
I thought I thought that was a bit weird
myself I only saw that yesterday when I
was you know creating examples using the
latest assets and we had some other
versions there was a there was one where
it was just blue but it wasn't bold okay
we didn't really like that comparison
look I yeah is this is do we have a demi
bold or something do we have any
possibilities along those lines or do we
not have that in the notebook we do but
in the cloud interface Yan and I have
tried to keep
our fonts pretty restricted so it might
look a little bit different you know
that was a concern there right and you
also I mean III don't Mac does Demi bold
pretty well but windows idea um it could
just be black and slightly larger what's
it it already is slightly larger it's
one because this tried in black is that
not I mean is that hopeless could you
try this can can you can you Marcus for
us I'm sure there's some overlap what
was the what was the question
yeah the request to mark up this without
bold sure thing um okay do i what about
these other icons is there a library of
these other icons here can we see if you
oh yeah you don't have them in the
assets but if in the scope section I
have I think I have but you know I think
I have all of them okay fine let's just
take a look oh yeah okay yeah that looks
weird if I might say so I mean it looks
like some kind of strange square headed
creature with two eyes and a mountain um
could whoever's making that background
noise please try to figure out how you
cannot do that the um okay so
I think this is crazy and I don't see
the reason to have a dot dot there I
would just tell them we may already look
silly with the eyes but just have double
quotes that just have bigger double
quotes and forget the dot thought that
my Sokka there was a previous version
that I think Jeremy may have mocked up
and your feedback at that time boys to
include ellipsis right and the and we
use the ellipses and basically all of
them right we have a live Caesar grid
and right are how do you avoid this
effect you see the effect I'm seeing oh
maybe you don't see it Matt I think
maybe we I think I think the problem is
that they're sort of angled but not
really curly right so maybe we either
need to make them normal double quotes
or really proper curly quotes yeah maybe
maybe if you bring down the size of the
dots there it would help if we can do
that consistently for these cases where
they're annotated the other things that
if you get rid of the little frame and
you just had the arrows it wouldn't
provide as much of a head shape yeah but
I'm not sure you can do that with it it
depends on the blue right yeah okay so
anyway I'm giving you that feedback
that's that's some
you
not in the case of something other than
a list so if it's a list it's just a dot
dot dot is that correct
or no those are brace brackets around it
oh my gosh okay I can list the special
cases if you like yeah please - so
there's lists that's one dimension list
that's more than one dimension
Association that's one dimension
Association that's more than one
dimension Association that's more than
one dimension look like it looks like
the the array of dots between the
Association brackets I see I see okay we
have data set which I don't think we
have an example of here string and then
the fall through to what the fall
through case I've said too much I was
very confused there okay we haven't yet
added the vulture icon but we can yeah
yeah I know right okay so um let's just
take a look for a
um
let's look just as an example here of
something real let's just understand how
it works with something from the data
repository okay let's take come let me
just pull up something random here
meteorite landings here resource data
there okay so now we would say icon eyes
this
but needs to be fixed
ah so there's the data set icon nice
that seems pretty good to me so what
you're telling me is if I take that
thing and I say D s equals oops what
happened here
I did a copy and it went bonkers
and then I do paste that right and I say
D s equals that then then that will be
what it should be so to speak yes
head of the esses today's mm-hmm
wonderful that's really nice
you know I quite like this belly for
what it's worth I quite like this blue
perhaps even better than the the greyish
blue of the that term too big thing I
just I mean it just has to be we just
have to have consistency yeah
plus there's also the autocomplete blue
the suggestion bar blue they're all kind
of all different okay well okay maybe
maybe we can have some differences but
we need to at least know what we're
doing
yep okay well I'm decently happy with
this these icons I could live with all
of these icons right now but I think
there's some tweaking that would be nice
did you sorry Billy did you get that
mock-up of the thing without the bold
face hey yes okay what does some other
example use bold face do we have any
other summary boxes where we use bold
face
now
ones where they've been given a name
nah
search
[Music]
okay so Billy let me know when but it's
the is it going in your folder yeah you
could start heading over there and then
I'm gonna die back oh wow okay
no you were waiting liquor to me so if
you go if you go in there and go to LCC
and then should be unbold so there it's
bigger not bold same level of I think
that looks like I anybody want to have
gap yeah I don't know that it needs to
be any bigger than it already was trying
to try it work down a size here okay
leave that one on there we can compare
okay
let's let's move on so we happy that
this was basically a graphic design
story right so I have a couple of
questions one is whether we want to
document the fact that it returns an
ionized object construct we don't have a
breath page for I can eyes object not
document that for right now okay right
and I guess the question is right it so
I made a note about evaluate in place
since that's certainly going to be I
think a common thing they don't know if
that should be an example here or I
should just tell Chris Carlson that he
should create a workflow for this why
would a very much in place becoming
because you have something blobby you
want so right you could do your example
in one step if you had your resource
data example in one step if you had
written BS equals I can eyes of oh I see
I see I see I see I see two valley I
didn't read it carefully to evaluate I
can eyes of exper yeah that's happened
yeah right
I see so what you're saying is what I
would do is I would take range of 50 dot
range of 50 for example and then in that
input code I would just say well what
would I do I would put in I would say
there I can eyes so there's a certain
argument that the right-click menu
should contain I can eyes that would be
useful
Roman brought up this possibility and
pull request review as well I think we
should certainly consider it it might be
an expensive operation for so what yeah
I mean we've all kinds of crud in here
we think that will be a very useful one
um I wonder whether in the cloud whether
that's a way to do that also because we
don't have general evaluate in place in
the cloud at this time although I think
it I think John said it was coming
nobody no no no we're still hearing that
background noise could somebody please
try to UM okay go ahead yeah I have an
objection to it being I mean I guess
what happens if you select something
that's not a valid expression right it
has to be possible does it destroy you
know just nothing well it does nothing
actually I don't even know what that did
I don't I don't even know what the
behavior is there it's not something
it's happened actually but I it probably
should be it didn't beep right that's a
question Lou do you know the answer to
that maybe but that has not been
something that has come up big time but
listen okay so action items here you
know Chris and you need to work on a
workflow for this okay
we need to understand the right-click
menu and we need to understand what
happens in the cloud
reasonable yep okay so while we're
talking abou is it should it be related
at all to the Blues that are in
information on that notebook to the left
there or oh boy we've got so many blues
running around there from the
documentation right those those match
the ref pages from okay the use of break
right I think different purposes should
be different yes right I think there's a
question for Jeremy Billy should bring
it up Jeremy isn't here as you know no
he's not here we have talked about it
and you think you were there for this
conversation where the blue for the
progress panel and would sort of match I
can eyes because these are things that
are sort of in transit or otherwise fine
I that yeah okay all right we Billy did
you have that one last sample for us I
think you'd be able to refresh yeah
so original letting pixels pixels I
think 11 pixels is fine what do you
think that's what I think fine let's go
with it
okay all right I think that's everything
for Billy here to my knowledge
unless he's involved with success sounds
sounds wonderful
okay is there gonna come up to blues
again I don't know you have let's take a
look let's take a look let's let's do
how do we get a success out I'll send
myself something um
you
no it's only great what the heck
happened to that check mark her check
mark is some crazy bitmap
Wow that is for you this is because I'm
125% why is that checkmark looking
blobby like that
probably the resources some P&G or
something take a look at that real quick
okay something suddenly went wrong there
oops that wasn't the right thing visited
the right dimensions we are using
characters for those but like an actual
check mark just resized but maybe not
well Billy that's for you and all for
such much a check up on I think own okay
okay isn't the ordering of the things
and the success object wrong it was
supposed to say mail sent or something
so that was our the questions we there
are all sorts of things here
so is shadi here is or do we what what
is the I mean limit the shadi have some
definite opinion that is different from
some previous opinion that we had I
don't think she does she was just
passing around back the feedback from
Monday's meeting that you wanted to have
a description as the first item yes and
because I think this is utterly obscure
nobody wants to see this message ID
right I think the message ID being first
is just an ordering problem right I also
think the tag is not that important I
think what we really want just like in
failure you know if you understand your
shows the tech so here no no no the
failure does not show the type of
failure shows does it I mean the failure
shows how do I get a good failure I can
do interpreter of city frog oh that's
probably some city called frog somewhere
no okay so first of all it has a message
right which is nice and human readable
okay I agree it has a tag yes
and so I I have no problem so if we want
a mirror failure then that that's fine
it has a message which might be just
mail sent
but I think it should be right I think
we need a message with a message
template otherwise there's no way to
localize these okay fine and actually
your point that we can call it message
is probably okay I mean you're
suggesting we call it message I maybe
had a different suggestion where it was
an unnamed field which doesn't actually
make a lot of sense right
so okay message mail sent seems fine to
me okay and then if you want you know
whether tag mate sit above the fold or
not I don't think it's terribly
important what do you think do you have
a C that's useful that's useful I mean
if what you actually saw above the fold
was message sent recipient blah blah
blah it is a little confusing that the
message says message sent right I mean I
was I was not super crazy about the tag
to begin with but I think tag might be
programmatically useful I also don't
understand why they why the alignment is
the way it is here but that's a
different issue I mean so with new style
messages the tag is hidden it's only in
the tool tip yes well I wouldn't be
horrified by having failure have the tag
be under the fold so do we want right
but tag is a required field I think it's
certainly a required argument so yes I
think that that's a good idea because I
think it allows it to be
programmatically handled so should then
so does that mean that irrespective of
whatever else happens tag is then the
first field under the fold
have a strong opinion about that I think
it's a decent seems like a good idea
right now
okay then I think simplifying failure to
not have the tag if that is consistent
with all the uses of failure seems
reasonable to me that success would have
you know it's a pity we have to call it
message especially because our first
example of success is with message sent
unless we call it mail sent now mail
sent will be okay message : mail sent
although we're going to have the same
thing um you know when we end up with
them SMS messages which actually we have
in this version um we'll end up with a
message : message sent do we want to
call it message that's the question you
know I think the other thing there the
other name you proposed for it
previously was description but there is
kind of a nice symmetry of having it be
a message yeah yeah let's call it
message okay and let's have the message
be for send mail be mail sent and then
let's have recipient as the next thing
and then under the fold we can have the
message ID in the tag okay if you think
we want the ordering of the tag first in
the in in under the fold fine I don't
feel strongly about it if I think it
should be consistent so I suppose it
could be last I think the loss wouldn't
be bad but it should be sort of in a
consistent location okay I'd recommend
lost any objectives no I think that's
fine for the message mail sent that's
mail sent as like a sentence not came
back it straight that is correct mm-hmm
it's tag happens to be mail sent as well
right yeah someone is asking why are the
success and failure boxes this is this
is what we get for having that this is
good this is public comment whyever
success and failure box is gray not blue
because because all of our summary boxes
are gray and we want it to have a
different distinctly different color for
the agonised blob yes right yeah our
success and failure copy-paste able
presumably they are able now well people
are foolishly still forcing forcing
interpretable to false right outputs
copy/paste of all no no depends on your
meaning of copy/paste of all Oh the
large output no no I was talking
specifically about summary boxes right
yes sure the answer is yes right it's
just an interpretation box that
evaluates to out of N and it's just a
really big thing to copy and paste er
but it's not it doesn't have the data
it's just out of it literally out of n
is the interpretation I see all right
can we move on please
um okay we're done with success so to
speak
yep let's do few tries success just for
um at the end if you want to delete the
that excluded cell that I put in there
so I wouldn't forget anything I wanted
to know how to just delete explode
that's interesting alright I'll fix it
but ok onward basin code base decode is
our last thing and then if Eric can let
the guys for the next meeting now was
slightly later um okay
basin code so pretty straightforward
well the current implementation is
straightforward you can take a byte
array no it might write what what
happens if I just want to do this then
you need to convert it to a byte array
using string to byte array
that's kind of obnoxious I mean what why
not support the string because you get
into interpretation problems explain V
[Music]
this the right a string is not a list of
bytes a string is a string and then
depending on the character encoding that
may or may not correspond to one or more
bytes and write to an array of bytes
character here could be encoded in all
kinds of crazy ways or something is that
your point I would like big-endian
little-endian all that kind of crazy
stuff
now I mean like the fact that write the
code point of alpha is 9 4 5 which is
not a a bite I understand that right
it's a multi bite character which could
be inserted in different ways on the
string right right all right okay
okay huh so we could conceivably well I
know III I was going to recommend that
we do this as experimental for now
anyway I think that wouldn't be a bad
idea and sort of I put a question in
there you realize that this has failed
again this this some this get function
no no not work this guy space D code
got the
have one encoding we probably have 15
base 60 and base 85 yes definitely
you
right so the question is about I think
we should support both names RFC 204
five and maybe base 64 line breaks okay
I mean I think I think supporting a
standard name for this is a perfectly
reasonable thing to do if that's you
know what it's typically referred to as
okay um and the names for those other
ones I think it should just say base I
would think that what we should do is
say base in code I mean these things are
you know when it says base whatever it
is I mean it's you know okay so let's
say bytearray range of 10 or something I
think we should just say base 85 here
like that all right but which will go to
prison I don't remember if you know 46
48 includes the base 85 but presumably
it'll go to whatever is the most current
or if see version and then in the future
you know and then the other variant well
yeah right if we really if there are
variant issues we could use a method
option for the RFC okay right well so
sort of right well so the issue is that
for example base 64 is described both by
RFC 2045 and 46 48 only those are
slightly different version well then I
think we should use a method option I
think we pick a default and use a method
option for those RFC so I'm recanting my
previous statement about I mean maybe we
could offer as an alternative just
putting in the encoding RFC 2045
hmm but I think more explicitly it will
be based in code blah blah blah
you know base64 comma method arrow RFC
2045 I mean that would be extremely
clear in terms of people reading code
and things okay okay so base decode
so now in order to do a basically code
the default based D code will just be
base64
yep and then this would be byte array -
byte array - expression right or normal
a byte array
hmm if you want to see the bite it's
normal if you want to convert it to a
string of data then you know um okay
all right this seems good is there any
other thing we want to point this to
registering oh those are sensible don't
we want to point these to import and
export yeah well
and import string and export strings
should point to these as well okay did
you rolling could be further up in that
list I don't think so because URL encode
is a text to text transformation not a
binary to text transformation no but
still conceptually people are going to
look for it there aren't they I'm not
sure I'm just asking my initial
inclination is no but maybe if we ask
somebody like Ricardo or Carlo they'd
have a different opinion right
my tendency would be to agree with Brett
here um okay I think we're done and
anything more that we need to go over
for this some nope in this collection
okay
thanks all I'll push these changes and
see y'all later